many people who watch the big bang
theory when you came in they were kind
of like why are they putting her in you
were upsetting the apple cart sure and i
think also they were bringing me in you
know
as the female version you know was what
i was told of everybody's beloved
favorite character played by um jim
parsons who's incredible and people
loved him so much the way he was there
was a huge risk
that a do we need a female version of
the person that we love who also was
identified as very kind of like asexual
and not interested in females and there
was a lot of um
a lot of sort of negative stuff from
some of the super fans at first were you
nervous when you went into that show you
know i had never seen it i don't watch
tv so i had never seen the big bang
theory i had heard about it because they
mentioned me like the real person miami
alec but i thought it was a game show
when someone said oh they mentioned you
on big bang theory so i had never seen
it i didn't know who jim parsons was uh
i would think that somebody in the field
that you're in show business and acting
would need to watch television and would
want to watch the show before they
auditioned or whatever well so i mean i
was on a tv show when i was 14 to 19.
blossom and then i actually took 12
years off backtrack for a second your
parents were very conservative type
people they're old fat like it was
always the 1940s my whole life right and
so you're home and you're living there
and you are in some school plays and how
do you get in a bette midler film so um
i was i wasn't a hammy kid but i was def
there was i was a an unusual kid i was
one of those like oh she's an old soul
there's something weird about this right
in other words you were a little kid who
really knew how to handle herself on
stage yeah but again that comes from
more the house that i grew up in there
was a tremendous amount of
emotional and psychiatric stuff floating
around in my family so i was i was a
manager of emotions and what my parents
did is they they literally my mom said
i'll open the yellow pages we'll see if
there's a kid's agent that wants to
handle you literally they you know they
wrote a letter on a typewriter because
that's what people used in their mid-80s
and this agent picked me up she was
actually neil patrick harris's agent she
was um she saw you even she was johnny
galecki's agent and she just said like
there's something about this kid she
looks like bette midler and barbara
streisand she's a weird little you know
i mean i was all features you know i was
like 11 years old and just nose and chin
and that was a pretty successful movie
called beaches right that was a year
after i started acting and beaches you
go in and you're working with the
legendary bet medler you're playing a
small version of her yes right you're
playing the young version of it i didn't
realize like i'd get my own tv show when
that came out and that's literally what
happened it felt very surprising to me
what was happening in my life and when
you're that young you don't realize how
lucky you are in terms of this well like
i said like my grandparents were
immigrants from eastern europe so
anything but the holocaust was lucky
when you got blossom or even the bette
midler movie it suddenly changed
everyone's perception of you you became
the popular kid no i became the
unpopular kid is that really true i mean
i was i was never popular-ish in the
first place yeah i mean like i said i
was i was a weird kid i i was always
strange i was never never ever you're
the only person who's ever called me
normal no when i became um you know sort
of a famous person i went to very
academically rigorous programs and all
that was emphasized was academics are
you super intelligent i mean have you
ever had
i was in all those special nerd programs
when you go to ucla is everyone looking
at you like hey there's bo i walked off
of your television like into the quad
and i was a super nerd like i studied
all the time and you know like people
would yell at me across the quad like
hey blossom you know but i just like i
kept my head down i sat in the front row
i wasn't i think also you know anytime
you go to a large university like that
you're not the smartest person and my
parents always told me i was the best i
was the smartest like that's not true
and at ucla i was like at the bottom of
my class i had to struggle to get b
minuses in organic chemistry yeah and
when you go to college and you know
you're growing up and you want to
experiment with boys and all that kind
of stuff are you then nervous that that
the guys want to bang you because you're
i'm still nervous about that sure why
after going to college realizing that
perhaps there was more to life than show
business after blossom right why why did
you go back i was running out of health
insurance so i figured if i can audition
like if i can get sag insurance at least
i'll have health insurance but
originally i wanted to be a research
professor and i had my first son and i
really fell in love with being with him
and breastfeeding on demand and i didn't
expect that i'd so much want to be like
the full-time mom so that was sort of a
shift i knew i wanted to finish my phd
and i did but i also knew
i'd probably end up teaching i taught
for about five years after i got my phd
but then i started auditioning for
things and i didn't expect to be on a tv
show like that was not part of the plan
at all so when they called they called
you for big bang theory no i started
going on any auditions that come down
the pike i have an amazing manager she
took me on when i was eight months
pregnant with my second son she said
after you have your kid let's have some
fun let's see what we can do but no i
did like i mean i i did a couple lines
on bones a couple lines on saving grace
like it's not like doors open for you if
you were blossom like i started from
scratch i auditioned for big bang theory
with a bunch of other very competent
actresses and i scored the part i don't
know how just crazy my life